you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
how swift action to cut methane
pollution would rapidly reduce the rate
of global warming
while the science museum is facing
criticism for its controversial sponsor
of a new
climate exhibition and the indonesian
eco warrior turning central javas
mountains
green
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions we aim to take you to the
hearts of the climate
crisis explain the data driving the
changes that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come
now when we talk about global warming
there's usually a big focus on
one greenhouse gas in particular carbon
dioxide
but it's far from the only reason that
our planet is heating up
well our science correspondent thomas
moore is here with me so thomas tell us
more
well we're not going to keep global
warming below 1.5 degrees unless we
dramatically cut emissions of another
greenhouse gas
methane that's the conclusion of the
united nations environment program
in a new report it says methane is 10
times more powerful than carbon dioxide
at trapping heat in the atmosphere yet
levels have more than doubled
since pre-industrial times so where's it
all coming from
well the report says human activity
accounts for around 380 million
tons of methane being released every
year agriculture
mainly livestock and rice cultivation
accounts for 40
but fossil fuels and waste including
landfill
are also significant sources the good
news is that existing solutions could
reduce methane emissions from
human activity by 45 by 2030 that's
180 million tons a year
so thomas what are some of those
solutions that you were talking about
there
well you could manage coal mines better
you could detect leaks in gas pipes you
could
reduce food and organic waste going to
landfill you could cut down the amount
of meat you're eating and also
grow rice more sustainably action now in
the 2030s
could reduce the the rise in global
temperatures by 0.3 of a degree
by the 2040s so it's quite significant
and
all this is about keeping that
temperature rise down isn't it yes you
can see the numbers just ticking up the
whole time can't you and it's rare that
we have a win-win when we're talking
about the climate but this
is good for the planet it's good for our
health it's good for the economy
too and remember uh that this is swift
and significant holding down those
temperature rises
one scientist has said if we're talking
about trying to meet those
paris climate gold targets of 1.5
degrees
you need to use every climate trick in
the book and on page one
should be methane emissions thomas thank
you
and on this week's climate cast we're
talking carbon emissions from how much
the amazon rainforest absorbs to the
role of our oceans
in tackling climate change that's
available from tomorrow wherever you
normally get your podcast from
and now in today's other climate news
boris johnson has told a meeting of
ministers from 35 countries that the uk
is doing everything it can
to make the cop 26 climate summit in
november a success
the prime minister said the conference
being held in glasgow
needs to produce concrete action
otherwise there's no chance of keeping
our planet cool
[Applause]
more than a quarter of the world's total
greenhouse emissions came from
china in 2019 exceeding combined
emissions from the developed world
for the first time research from u.s
based think tank the rhodium group
said china was responsible for more than
14 gigatons of co2
that's triple its level in 1990. china
has vowed to bring total emissions down
from 2030 and be carbon neutral by 2060.
[Applause]
the royal botanic gardens queue are
encouraging people to reconnect with
nature
this summer with the secret world of
plants celebrating british biodiversity
it features large-scale immersive
plantscapes
representing contrasting landscapes from
across the uk
from moorlands to sand dunes
conservationists in chile are
reintroducing the rear to its native
home in the patagonia region
where the flightless bird is almost
extinct because of illegal hunting
ria's largely vegetarian diet makes them
an essential part of the ecosystem
helping distribute seeds through the
region last month
14 rears were released into patagonia's
national park by tompkins conservation
who are aiming to get a hundred adults
into the wild
and scientists in the us have found an
eco-friendly way to cut the grass
a group from the university of
california are ditching traditional
lawn mowers and instead they're allowing
sheep to graze on campus lawns
they're hoping using the four-legged
lawn mowers
will lower emissions and increase
biodiversity in the area
now in two weeks time the science
museum's newest exhibition will open
and it's all about carbon capture but
climate
activists are calling for people to
boycott it and that's because
oil company shell is the major sponsor
of the exhibition something
many of those who've contributed to the
exhibits aren't happy about
our climate correspondent lisa holland
reports
[Applause]
london's science museum is preparing to
reopen after lockdown
with the uk's first exhibition on
capturing carbon
the main attraction is a future climate
solution
a full-scale mechanical tree brought
over from america
it replicates how trees naturally soak
up
carbon dioxide it's widely accepted that
technology to capture carbon
and store it will be needed for the uk
to get to net
zero by 2050 but amongst
some contributors like the climate
scientist involved in this display on
capturing carbon in woodlands
the excitement of taking part has been
overshadowed
by learning the exhibition is being
sponsored by the oil company
shell on the one hand i want to support
the exhibition
and the the key messages of the
exhibition but then on the other hand
i don't want to be associated with
sponsorship by
big oil companies the museum has
defended its choice of sponsors
actually we keep complete editorial
control of our exhibitions
no matter the sponsor so
they're actually not no sponsor is ever
involved in the exhibition per se
shells says its target is to become a
net zero emissions energy business by
2050
and it has a long-standing relationship
with the science
museum which is planning to open the
exhibition in two weeks time
lisa holland sky news central london
new research by the royal college of
psychiatrists has found
two-thirds of people in the uk say
climate issues are affecting their
mental health and 84 percent
think it'll have an impact in 10 years
time so how can we care for the planet
and our mental well-being well professor
lorraine whitmarsh is an environmental
psychologist
at the university of bath and joins me
now welcome to you
so just how big a problem do you think
that climate anxiety is
i think it is something which we don't
know very much about to be honest we do
know
that the majority of the public say that
they are very concerned about climate
change
but the percentage that say that it's
something which is
impacting on their quality of life in
significant ways for example not being
able to sleep
or disruption to work is extremely low
um
actually we're seeing that a lot of
people that do express concern about
climate change tend to channel that into
doing something positive
about uh about the environment so
actually it's not always necessarily
a problem i think and to what extent do
you think these are generalized concerns
about the future of the planet
are they more specific people worrying
say that their
local area could flood in the future or
they could be
subject to more droughts
i think what we've found is that
generally it tends to be a rather more
abstract concern people are
worried about um various aspects of
climate change
but in the uk at least it tends to be an
issue which people
think will affect people in other
countries and future generations more
than
themselves personally so i think it is
probably a bit more of an abstract
concern
for the majority of people at the moment
but but clearly
it is an issue so what would your advice
be to anyone who
is worried about the environment who has
climate anxiety
i mean i think people who say that it is
significantly affecting
their mental health obviously have to um
probably seek
help with that i mean i think that there
aren't many people for whom it is a
significant disruption but if that is
causing them a greater anxiety
they can get medical support but i think
what we generally um
advocate is that the more people can um
look into ways in which they can do
their bit to actually help address
climate change the more they can join up
with
like-minded people join groups that are
taking action on climate change
and get social support and also feel
part of a collective effort to take
action
the more they're likely to feel that
they aren't helpless actually in terms
of what climate change
uh the impacts that it's going to have
so i think sort of channeling that
anxiety into positive action
is generally um something that we would
recommend
professor lorraine whitmarsh thanks very
much indeed
now in the latest of our series of
climate diaries we hear the story
of 69 year old saddeman from indonesia
over nearly 25 years of hard work he
succeeded in turning the previously
barren hills around central java
green providing water for local
communities in the process
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that's all for today on the daily
climate show tomorrow how you can help
save britain's
only spiny mammal under threat because
of our changing climate
you can catch that tomorrow here on sky
news at 6 30 and 9 30 and on our social
channels
thanks for watching see you then
you